- If it was possible to
take out my human heart and hand it over,
I would give it to the great Billy Porter.
Please say hello.
(audience applauding)
(screaming)
(upbeat music)
- I know you can't touch me
- I know, I know
- I hate it.
- I hate it, too.
(Laughter)
- Lee Harris and I picked out this outfit.
- We kinda have on the same shoes
- I know, by the way.
- Warrior on the back.
Ruthie Davis come on.
- Oh.
- Come on here.
- Those are amazing.
- Your dear friend
Christian Siriano was here.
- I'm gonna see him tomorrow.
- I think the outfit that
the two of you created
might be one of the most historic
fashion moments in modern history.
- [Billy] Thank you.
- [Drew] It's true.
- [Billy] Thank you.I appreciate that.
- [Drew] I mean, there has
never been anything like it,
it was the most original
outside the box thinking,
and yet it looked like
it had always been there.
It was one of those aha
moments if I've ever seen one.
- [Billy] Well, you know,
what's interesting about
that for me is that,
being in drama school with
all my friends and stuff,
you know, we would like talk about it.
Oh, I'm going to wear
a gown to the Oscars.
I don't understand why men only
get to wear that, you know,
wear suits, the penguin suit,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And you know, it's rooted
in this masculinity thing,
you know, masculinity being
the top of the food chain.
And as a man, as a
black man, particularly,
if you can't
inhabit
masculinity
in the way that society expects
you to or requires you to,
it's a problem.
And so I find that there are
many men who on the red carpet
would play, you know,
would have fun if it weren't for
the masculinity gotcha, gotcha.
So I plucked myself out of that game.
- I know what it's like to be
pigeonholed as a certain thing.
- [Billy] Yeah.
- When I was like a child actor,
- [ Billy] Yeah.
- Then I was a bad girl.
- And you have broken
through every stereotype
or every narrative that
you thought might be a,
a trapping and created your
own world, let alone a novel.
- Well, you know, I have to say,
I'm so grateful for the time.
You know, I think we, in
our culture specifically,
everything's a rush, you know.
We're in this microwave life.
(fingers snapping)
- [Drew] More and more.
- We're this more quick, faster.
(mumbles)
- It has to happen.
- Convenience
- And I took myself out of
it needed to happen by
such a certain date.
And living in that space was just like
one foot in front of the other,
leaning into my authenticity
that everybody told me
was gonna be my liability.
And it was my liability
for decades.
- You said something.
- Until it wasn't.
- That really was it
a very important thing
for myself to hear,
who is all about self improvement and
I'm not very kind to myself
as I'm going through it.
- I got you. I'm learning
self-compassion myself.
I've been working on it during quarantine.
- And good for you.
(applauding)
And I'm so good with other people, like.
- Always with other people.
- I would never treat everyone
on the way I treat myself.
- Which is ridiculous.
- Which is nuts.
- Yeah.
- But you said there is a
quote that you chose you.
What was choosing you? What
did that ultimately feel like?
Because to me it's not as
self-congratulatory thing,
it's a very brave thing.
- Well, you know,
I was in the valley and I was
in the valley for a long time.
You know, I always say
it's easy to be who you are
when what you are is what's popular.
Who I, who I am was not popular.
And I just said, you know what?
This is what it is. This is my truth.
And whatever comes of this is
what's supposed to come of this.
- Today is very special
for us. And, you know,
I was reading about how, when you were
in like the Vogue scene and you know,
I was studio 54, we sort
of had this bon vivant
like wonderful cultural upbringing of
living and expression
and people, you know.
Their hearts are sort of
like these shooting stars
very much like the set
you're about to step on
for our first inaugural Sing to a Flower.
- I love Sing to a Flower
- Well, this idea is gifted
to us by none other than
Jimmy Fallon,
who he's married to my business partner,
Nancy Juvonen Fallon of 25 years,
we built Flower Films together.
So we've made everything together.
And he said, I have to
gift you guys this idea,
because it turns out that
if you sing to a flower,
there is scientific evidence
that it helps it grow.
And it was only a seed of
an idea, pun intended then,
(light laughter)
but here we are with Billy
Porter about to sing a song,
which I would love for you
to tell us about, edelweiss.
- You know, it's a flower that blooms
in the harshest of environments. You know,
and it teaches us that
we can and must flourish
in the darkest of times.
And I know that this is a really
dark time for a lot of us.
And you know, this song
is a, is a song of hope.
It's a song of peace and of love.
That's all we got right now.
You know, that's all we can do is
show up and make sure that
we represent the change
as individuals that we want
to see as the collective.
- Well, between Jimmy Fallon's gift to us
and his seed of an idea
and what you met it with
with picking this song
that lyrically is so apropos of this year
and of this moment,
I think your two ideas come
together and it's like,
candide Voltaire, cultivate the garden.
(laughter)
Let's, let's kick this off in
the most extraordinary way.
That's so beyond our wildest dreams,
(upbeat music)